la femme de benjamin castaldi m'a envoyé
un petit sms ir qui disait elle est
mariée l'animatrice à côté de mon mari
moins d'interrogations sur elle parle de
sophie koch bah oui elle a peur que
benjamin castaldi a mellow ste sophie
koch a aussi la cote lacoste au polo
peut-être offre est même bon coin à il
aime beaucoup
alors bien sûr malgré cela dit ma femme
voulait dire je veux vous demander de
rassurer votre femme en direct aux
demandes et de rassurer votre ferme en
direct sur cette caméra
voilà whissell l'afp regardez cette
caméra suivait des yeux c'est la
capitale elle me dit pareil sur bouder
est-ce qu'il est marié et damon a aucun
doute possible tant que ça pour être
votre style sophie cost non non on est
alors montré vérité parce que j'ai
toutes les caméras grave oui à la maison
je pense que je n'ai je les fais aucun
commentaire
et si vous avez quelque chose et que
vous balancez attention à ta au même on
sait que des coureurs qua non oui
j'aimerais les trompeurs j'ai des
coureurs méricourt s'est pas dites
c'est le coincer le forrest gump de la
chine à des cours et qu'on met la trame
jamais rien donne oui c'est une émission
pour faire divorcer des ravens
je vais rassurer votre femme ne
t'inquiète pas il aime que tout avoir
une sur wat il ne veut pas que de toi
vraiment je te dis à chaque fois toutes
les coupures pub et sophie et saufs
non vraiment le paquet
oui j'ai partie plus enfants week-end
avec benjamin je peux attester qu'il ne
bouge pas une oreille mais à ne laissez
pas le régime s'est dit noël dit
messieurs s'appuiera si ça bouge et on
le saurait